the New York Times takes on the First
Amendment Jim Acosta loves him some Jim
Acosta and we'll talk Supreme Court I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
I hope you had a wonderfully relaxing
weekend mine was actually quite nice
didn't matter show on Friday Bill Maher
show on Friday had a lot of fun bill and
I had a nice civil conversation about of
all things Russia and collusion which
was kind of interesting we'll get to
that a little bit later in the show but
first I want to remind you that we have
a special livestream which is happening
today at 7 p.m. Eastern we are joined by
special guest Jordan Peterson to
celebrate our Independence Day and
lament the fact that we don't actually
own Canada God King Jeremy boring will
host a new edition of daily wire
backstage with me and Andrew clay but in
the execrable michael moles to look back
on our country's birth and look ahead to
its future subscribers will even be able
to write in live questions for us to
answer on the air that is today at 7
p.m. Eastern 4 p.m. Pacific with Jordan
Peterson you can find our special lives
from on Facebook and YouTube but you're
not gonna want to miss it it's gonna be
a lot of fun so be there hey I'm gonna
be here so you better be here I mean
come on why else am i doing it okay so
go check that out also before we begin
let me remind you you should be dressing
better than you are okay you look like a
slob that's why you need to go out and
get yourself a nice custom suit I don't
mean one of these off the rack
monstrosity I mean something that makes
you look like James Bond and that's why
you need Indo Chino they're the world's
largest made-to-measure menswear company
they've been featured in major
publications including GQ Forbes and
Fast Company they make suits and shirts
made to your exact measurements for a
fantastic feat fit and guys that like
the wide selection of high quality
fabrics the option to personalize all
the details including lapel wining
monogram here's how it works you neither
go over to one of their showrooms and
many of America's major cities and pick
out all of your customizations and
personalizations and they can tailor it
directly for you there and then they
sends it off and then it shows up in
your mailbox or you can do it at Indo
Chino com you send in all of your
customizations and your measurements and
then you wait for your custom suit to
arrive in just a few weeks and it fits
great this week my listeners can get any
premium Indo Chino suit for just 379
bucks at Indo Chino comm when you enter
promo code Shapiro's at checkout
I went over the Santa Monica showroom
and it was just a lot of fun one of my
favorite suits is that suit it's
certainly the one that fits me the best
nice three-peat kind of piece blue suit
with our best it's pretty snazzy that's
50% off the regular price for a
made-to-measure premium suit 379 bucks
at ENSO Chino calm when you enter promo
code Shapiro's at checkout and shipping
is free that's Indo Chino com promo code
Shapiro any premium suit just 379 bucks
free shipping as well again there's no
reason for you look like a slob endo
Chino will get you the best suit that
you can buy so check it out alright so
one of the nice things for President
Trump is that every time President Trump
does a normal thing the left decides
that the world has ended it really that
the world has gone crazy and I used as
evidence of this the fact that I was on
Bill Maher's show on Friday and I was
really more expecting the conversation
to surround the things that bill and I
have in common such as opposition to
political correctness and aversion to
identity politics and instead the entire
interview turned into 10 minutes about
Russia collusion which again if you are
if you are obsessed with the Russia
collusion story at this point let me
suggest that your priorities are not
straight there's no evidence to suggest
right now the president Trump has
colluded with Russia during the campaign
or afterward there's just not okay if
the evidence were there I would talk
about it because I've been very fair
about this but I'm not going to pretend
that there was a lot of evidence there
the point is this the folks on the left
have decided that president Trump must
be ousted by any means and they've
decided that President Trump represents
a great break in America's history and
they believe that America itself is
deeply broken and so now the left has
decided the deep American institutions
not Donald Trump other key American
institutions these institutions must be
destroyed as well they believe the
Supreme Court now has to be packed that
they need 11 justices on the Supreme
Court instead of 9 because maybe that
way they can get more liberal Supreme
Court justices they believe that the
First Amendment must be overthrown
there's an article in The New York Times
it is 2,000 words long it is not an
opinion piece it is a reported piece
from Adam libtech okay Adam libtech is
one of the reporters who is on a one of
the New York Times over the weekend and
the title of the piece is how
conservatives weaponized the First
Amendment how conservatives weaponized
the First Amendment now you may ask
yourself what does that even mean how
conservatives weapon how do you
weaponize the First Amendment it's a
right how do you weaponize a right
that's like saying that law abiding
citizens weaponized the freedom from
unreasonable search and seizure under
the Fourth Amendment how do you
weaponize that it doesn't make any sense
right but the New York Times believes
that conservatives have weaponized the
First Amendment because they don't like
the First Amendment that's right the New
York Times a newspaper dedicated
presumably to the proposition of freedom
of the press a newspaper that was
involved in some of the great free
speech cases in our nation's history
from the Pentagon Papers case led to the
two libel cases in the past the New York
Times now says that the First Amendment
has been too broadly construed that's
how far the left has been broken
they believe the
amendment must be curbed because it is
an institution of power the left is
always going on about how the reason the
left loses the reason the left is not
victorious is because the system itself
is corrupt if it weren't for the corrupt
system itself then Marxism would have
already taken over the world and
everything would be hunky-dory utopia
but in the United States where freedom
reigns they believe that the freedoms
themselves are a threat to the Marxist
worldview and so Freedoms themselves
must be torn down these are elements of
a hierarchical structure the first
amendment you might think when I say
freedom of speech that means anybody can
speak what the left says is what that
really means is only powerful people can
speak and that's why we need to crack
down on the First Amendment through
force of government the government has
to shut down free speech to save freedom
if that makes any sense to you that's
because you're so here is the New
York Times going on about there's Adam
Liptak he says on the final day of the
Supreme Court term last week justice
Elena Kagan sounded an alarm the courts
five conservative members citing the
first amendment had just dealt public
unions a devastating blow the day before
the same majority had used the First
Amendment to reject a California law
requiring religiously oriented crisis
pregnancy centers to provide women with
information about abortion conservatives
said Justice Kagan who's part of the
courts four member liberal wing were
weaponizing the First Amendment now I
just want to point out this is not a
court liberal wing it's a left-wing okay
it's a left-wing the differencing
liberal and left is that liberals
believe that we ought to maintain rights
like freedom of speech even if they
believe in more government intervention
in the economy the Left believes that
all of these rights ought to be subject
to the needs of the community that
basically communitarianism is the way
that if it violates their precepts of
the hierarchy of various power groups
then the First Amendment should be
subverted the New York Times says the
two decisions were the latest in a
stunning run of victories for a
conservative agenda that has been
increasingly been built on the
foundation of free speech notice how
that's that's worded and the way the New
York Times is working that is not that
the free speech agenda that has been
promulgated by the court helps
conservatives is that it is the
conservative agenda that is using the
mask of free speech in order to push
itself except for the fact that this
free speech agenda has nothing to do
with conservatism per se it just has to
do with the idea that you should be able
to say what you want without the
government compelling you conservative
groups building and borrowing on
arguments developed by liberals have
used the First Amendment to justify
unlimited campaign spending
discrimination against gay couples and
attacks on the regulation
tobacco pharmaceuticals and guns that's
a pretty radical take on what exactly
the Supreme Court just did instead what
the court just did is they said that the
government cannot compel you not to
spend on Elections that the government
cannot compel you to violate your own
religious precepts that the government
cannot compel you to say things you
don't want to say or pay money to unions
you don't want to join why exactly that
has to do with a conservative agenda is
beyond me that seems like just a
rational freedom agenda but you know
this is the New York Times they say the
Citizens United campaign finance case
for instance was decided on free speech
grounds with the five justice
conservative majority ruling that the
First Amendment protects unlimited
campaign spending by corporations the
government the majority said has no
business regulating political speech the
dissenters responded the First Amendment
did not require allowing corporate money
to flood the political marketplace and
corrupted democracy well that's a stupid
argument here the First Amendment does
require me to be able to speak as much
as I want and that involves me actually
spending money on things if the First
Amendment did not involve you spending
money on free speech then presumably the
government could pass a law saying that
corporations are not allowed to spend
money on say printed materials in the
sixty days before an election you know
it's a corporation that spends money on
printed materials sixty day before an
election the New York Times the New York
Times and the libertarian position has
become dominant on the right on the on
the right on First Amendment issues as
Ilya Shapiro a lawyer at the Cato
Institute
it simply means we should be skeptical
of government attempts to regulate
speech there used to be a nun
controversial and non ideological point
what's now being called the libertarian
position on speech was in 1960s the
liberal position on speech which is
exactly right right what Elliot Shapiro
is saying is you're calling it
right-wing this used to be the consensus
position and so much of American life
has become this so much of American life
is positions that all of America used to
hold and then the left decided it didn't
hold anymore and so the consensus
American position is now termed the
right-wing position so for example at
immigration the position that we should
enforce our borders the position that
perhaps we should actually police the
people coming into the country that was
a widespread 100 percent position in
America then the left decided that it
was intolerant and now that is a
right-wing position to say that we
should enforce our borders the same
thing on free speech it was a widely
held position across both sides of the
aisle that you should be able to say
basically what you want and then the
left decided
like that anymore and so what was left
was the right wing position but the way
that the New York Times posits the way
they pose it is is not that the left
throughout the first amendment it's that
the right decided to cling on to the
First Amendment in unreasonable fashion
why does the New York Times say that
well because they're the New York Times
as Andrew Klavan says a former newspaper
here's what the New York Times says
liberals and one's champion expansive
First Amendment rights are now uneasy
about them and many on the Left have
traded an absolutist commitment to free
speech from one sensitive to the harms
that it can inflict okay that's
hilarious
so they've decided that they're no
longer absolutist on free speech instead
they are more sensitive to the bad
things that can happen because of free
speech which is a way of saying then we
are not going to pay attention to free
speech at all if you trade in the harms
that can be inflicted by free speech for
free speech itself free speech is no
longer a right this is like saying that
there are certain harms that happen
because of the freedom from unreasonable
search and seizure and the Fourth
Amendment prevents the government from
coming into your home and simply just
checking out everything that's there for
the hell of it now are there societal
costs to that sure there's a societal
cost to that it means that not everybody
with drugs in their house is going to be
seen by the government for example not
everybody with an illegal gun in their
house is going to be seen by the
government but I'd much rather that a
few people have eally loans or illegal
drugs then the government have a blanket
right to come into my home at any time
for any reason without actually having
to give a rationale the minute that you
start saying that the downside of the
right is more important than the right
the right no longer exists but that's
what the left says left doesn't like the
rights the left does not like the free
speech rights so liberals were once
largely united in fighting to protect
sexually explicit materials from
government censorship now many on the
Left see pornography as an assault on
women's right in 1977 many liberals
supported the right of the American Nazi
Party to march among Holocaust survivors
in Skokie Illinois far fewer supported
the free speech rights of the white
nationalists who marched last year in
Charlottesville Virginia now there is a
difference by the way in these in these
two cases I will say that there's a
solid case we made justice boric would
be justice Bork judge Robert Bork once
made this case he said the pornography
is not protected by the First Amendment
there's a pretty good solid case that
the founders never intended for the
First Amendment to cover dirty pictures
but there's no question that the
founders intended for the First
Amendment to cover a political speech
which does involve Nazis marching
Skokie better First Amendment case just
legally speaking and historically
speaking for bad people marching than
for naked pictures in public but in any
case the New York Times says there's a
certain naivete and how liberals used to
approach free speech says Frederick
shower a law professor at the University
of Virginia because so many free speech
claims of the 1950s and 60s involved the
anti obscenity claims or civil rights
and anti-vietnam War protests it was
easy for the left to sympathize with the
speakers or believed that speech in
general was harmless but the claim that
speech was harmless or causally inert
was never true even if it has taken
recent events to convince the left of
that the question then is why the left
ever believed to otherwise so in other
words they were happy about free speech
when it was the anti-vietnam War
protests and civil rights and and
pornography but the minute that it turns
into religious Baker's who actually just
want to abide by their scruples then all
of a sudden left is ready to toss out
free speech which is to say the left was
never in favor of the right they were
just in favor of the of the exercise of
the right as they saw fit the left was
never in favor of that this is the big
problem with left the left doesn't
believe you have a right to do anything
the left disagrees with I believe as a
person on the right you have the right
to do lots of things I disagree with you
have the right to march in the street
with hats you have the right to to
act sexually how you want basically I
believe that you have the right to yeah
I actually believe the of the right to
smoke marijuana I think there are there
are lots of things that I believe have
the right to do that I personally find
abhorrent I hate marijuana I think it
smells and I think people who smoke it
are wasting their time and brain cells
but because I'm a freedom believing
person I also believe that there are
rights that extend to things I don't
like I think the right to free speech
extends to Nazis I hate Nazis there are
awful human beings but the rights of
free speech extends to them the same
thing does not hold true for the left if
you disagree with the left they want to
remove your rights and that's not
becoming obvious right now before we go
any further let's talk about your sleep
habits okay the reality is you are not
sleeping as well as you could be how do
I know well because you don't have a
helix sleep mattress working with the
world's leading sleep experts helix
sleep has developed a mattress that is
customized to your specific height
weight and sleep preferences so you can
have the best sleep of your life and an
unbeatable price so here's how it works
go to helix sleep calm
fill out there two minutes sleep quiz
they will design your custom mattress
they can even customize each side for
you and a partner in 2018 helix sleep
has taken customized sleep to the next
level with the helix pillow these all
new pillows are fully adjustable so you
can achieve perfect comfort regardless
of sleep position or
body type he looks sleep has thousands
of five-star reviews plus you get a
hundred nights to try them out by the
way I'm so I love helix sleep so much my
wife and I went out and got a helix
sleep mattress and we actually just
decided to give another one as a gift to
my sister for her wedding present she
was able to go through the process on
their website of selecting and
customizing the mattress for her and her
husband they could get different sides
of the mattress thread they wanted and
she's really excited for it to arrive he
looks sleep is just fantastic makes a
great gift it's also awesome for you
helix sleep comm slash men right now you
get up to 125 bucks toward your mattress
order that's helix sleep comm slash man
you up to 125 bucks off your mattress
order he looks sleep calm / man he looks
sleep is so good that my sister actually
asked for that I can't say that it was a
creative thought on my part she had
heard me talking about helix sleep she
asked me if helix sleep was really as
good as I said I said yes and she said
well can you get that from me for my
wedding so he could went out and got
that for us so helix sleep comm slash
men go check it out right now when you
use that slash pending get up to 125
bucks off your mattress order so back to
the left's perspective on free speech
really an incredible front-page story a
1 in the New York Times y free speech
should no longer apply according to
Catherine MacKinnon a law professor at
the University of Michigan free speech
reinforces and amplifies injustice free
speech makes the world worse quote once
a defense of the powerless the First
Amendment over the last hundred years
has mainly become a weapon of the
powerful it's not a weapon at all it
says the government can't impose on you
this is the difference between how the
left sees rights and how the right sees
rights the right sees rights as things
the government cannot touch inalienable
rights that pre-existed government the
left sees rights as things the
government gives to you and therefore if
it's bad for you the government can take
it away from you so free speech is bad
for you the government can take it away
the right says no you can't do that the
rights is that right pre-existed
government I didn't give up that right
to government when government was formed
the government exists to protect those
rights the left has no no no you didn't
have any rights then the government gave
you the right to free speech so if it's
bad for the community well then the idea
here is that we can take it away from
you using the power of government
MacKinnon says legally what was toward
the beginning of the 20th century a
shield for radicals artists activists
socialist and pacifists the excluded in
the dispossessed has become a sword for
authoritarian authoritarians racist and
misogynist Nazis and Klansmen
pornographers and corporations buying
elections in other words get rid of free
speech because the people I don't like
are using it and there's a long
discussion of Robert Bork and and this
and the and the sort of development of
free speech litigation and free speech
trends when they say the right turn has
been pronounced under Chief Justice
Roberts the Supreme Court has agreed to
hear a larger share of First Amendment
cases concerning conservative speech
than earlier courts had according to a
study prepared for the times it is ruled
in favor of conservative speech at a
higher rate than liberal speech as
compared to earlier courts the court
stock it reflects something new and
distinctive about the Roberts courts
according to the study the Roberts Court
more than any modern court has trained
its site on speech protecting
conservative at values only the current
court has resolved a higher fraction of
disputes challenging the suppression of
conservative rather than liberal
expression well the reason for that is
because there's very little suppression
of liberal expression in today's America
you can say whatever you want those
cases were already decided the real
crackdowns that are happening right now
our crackdowns from the left on the
right with regard to First Amendment
issues but the left says that we should
crack down on the First Amendment the
radicalization of the left is an ongoing
story that really is absurd and in just
a second I want to discuss that ongoing
radicalization first I want to talk a
little bit about the media so the media
the same media who are saying that the
First Amendment should be quashed for
everybody they don't like see themselves
his First Amendment warriors so Jim
Acosta over at CNN who loves him some
Jim Acosta I mean that dude loves Jim
Acosta get you somebody who loves you
who loves you the way Jim Acosta loves
Jim Acosta I mean really is a he's the
White House reporter for CNN and over
the weekend right before the weekend he
said he decided would be a worthwhile
thing to shout at president Trump's he's
standing in the back of the room
shouting a president Trump and then he
posted video of himself shouting at
President Trump as though Trump has some
sort of obvious obligation to answer Jim
Acosta shouting from the back of a room
now do I care that Jim Acosta shouts at
President Trump no I didn't care what a
writer at the Daily Caller neil munro
shouted president obama so it'd be
rather hypocritical of me to care that
Jim Acosta shouting at Trump but it just
goes to show you how when it was a
right-winger like neil munro
then it was the end of the world that he
shouted a question to Barack Obama Jim
Acosta does it and he's a hero so Jim
Acosta shouts at President Trump he's
shouting in him because there was a
shooting in a newsroom last week and the
media tried to pin it on President Trump
when it had nothing to do with President
Trump Jim Acosta shouting at the
president
[Applause]
I like the guy turning around his tush
again so there's a guy right in front of
him turning around and touching him and
then Jim Acosta gets to look to the
camera like I am so brave for saying
that look at these brave eyes whoo-hoo
so brave
okay so FoxNews says well you know that
was kind of inappropriate well all right
I don't really care about the
inappropriate of it it doesn't make a
huge difference to me
but the part of it that's hilarious is
that Jim Acosta then suggests that Fox
News is a threat to free speech
basically Jim Acosta goes on reliable
sources with brian Stelter I've appeared
on and brian has him on for basically
the entire hour I think he had him on
for this long segment which is an empty
hour I mean Jim Acosta not a lot going
on upstairs with Jim Acosta and this is
really really funny so first he starts
off by saying FoxNews is only angry at
me because they need someone to attack
well no I'm not really angry at you as
much as bemused by you Jim Acosta I'm
not I'm not angry Jim Acosta because I
don't think he's worthy of my anger but
I haven't been used by the fact that Jim
Acosta thinks he's such an important
human and I love that CNN now does the
navel-gazing routine where Jim Acosta is
a hero for having shouted out a question
and being shush by a bald guy in front
of him at the White House so here's
brian Stelter questioning him the
president Fox News they don't have
Barack Obama around anymore they don't
have Hillary Clinton although the
president goes after Hillary Clinton a
lot so does Fox News and so we've sort
of replaced Obama and Hillary they need
somebody to attack and I think that
we've sort of filled that role okay so
yeah that must be it it must be that
they're they're attacking you because
they don't have Obama to kick around
anymore or maybe they're attacking your
Mecosta because you're a highly
irritating human and to show how
irritating you are this is the best
thing ever so it cost us on with Stelter
and he's asked about shouting at the
president listen to the amount of just
drooling self-aggrandizement and in in
which Jim Acosta engages it's so
phenomenal here we go now of course
they're not going to take our questions
we have to find opportunities to ask
those questions and that's kind of like
Sam Donaldson did decades ago that's
right and listen if they want to send me
to hell I'll still be shouting at the
devil what what now if you want to send
me to hell I'll be shouted look how
brave I am so brave send me to hell I'll
shout at the devil and then the devil
will fart on you like what what is that
what does that even mean send me to hell
and I'll shout at the devil yes I'm so
brave and I am so tough we are so much
journalism aghh
Wow bravery ooh now the big question is
why Jim Acosta wasn't shouting at the
devil when it was a devil he liked right
why wasn't he shouting a Barack Obama
when it was somebody that you liked and
the answer is that Jim Acosta wasn't
shouting at him because he was busy
asking him kiss-ass questions and the
media the same media who say the First
Amendment should be curve read the New
York Times saying the First Amendment
should be curbed for you you know the
commoner the little person it should be
expanded for the press to the extent
that we have to force Donald Trump to
answer every question Jim Acosta might
have because Jim Acosta is a brave man
who shouts at the devil in hell you
dragged me down to Hades you put me on
that boat you send me across the river
Styx I'll face down the devil stare him
in his beady little eyes and then we
will have a face-to-face conversation me
and mr. scratch Jim Acosta but yeah when
it comes to the common person then of
course if you're religious Baker then we
have to force you to do what we want or
if you are a person who wants to give
money in an election cycle we have to
force you to do what we've used if
you're not a member of a union we have
to force you to pay money to a union the
double standard for people in the press
who believe free speech should apply to
them it should apply to nobody else is
pretty astonishing now speaking of
radicalization of the Democratic Party
what we've been watching in real-time is
a massive radicalization of the
Democratic Party so right now the person
who is receiving all sorts of plaudits
of course is this is this woman I always
forget first name Alexandra Alexandra
Ocasio Acacio Cortez I mean the reason I
forget her name is because I don't think
she's all that important but the media
are playing her as though she's deeply
important this of course is the 28 year
old former bartender who was who
defeated Joe Crowley who is a 58 year
old possible successor to Nancy Pelosi
as my house Minority Leader no honest
Asya or Alexandra's Cortes you know
Ocasio Cortes she defeated him we'll
talk about her in just a second first I
want to say thanks to our sponsors over
at policy genius so 71% of people say
they need life insurance 100% of people
need life insurance because everybody
gonna die and when you die you shouldn't
leave your family having to deal with
all of your
funeral expenses without having any
actual money in the bank also if you are
an earner then you owe it to your family
to have some sort of life insurance in
place right now only 59% of people have
coverage if you've been avoiding getting
life insurance or procrastinating well
don't do it because procrastination is
one of those things that will not work
with life insurance once you are dead it
is too late so go check it out a policy
genius com
it's the easy way to compare life
insurance online you can compare quotes
in just five minutes and when it's that
easy there's no reason to put it off you
can compare quotes while sitting on the
couch watching TV or while listening to
this show policy genius has helped over
4 million people shop for insurance
placed over 20 billion dollars in
coverage they don't just make life
insurance easy they also compare
disability insurance and renter's
insurance and health insurance if you
care about it they can cover it so if
you need life insurance but you've been
putting it off because it's too
confusing or you don't of the time
you're lying to yourself go check out
policy genius com it's the easy way to
compare those top insurers and find the
best value for you no sales pressure
zero hassle and it's free policy
genius.com again no reason for you not
to do it be a responsible human called a
policy genius calm and check it out okay
so the radicalization of the Democratic
Party continues apace Alexandria of
Stassi of Cortez at some point I'll
actually learn her name well enough that
I don't have to pause when saying it
because the media have turned her into
such a ubiquitous figure she is leading
the way she is leading the way and she
is an actual card-carrying member of the
Democratic socialists of America this is
a party that has about 37,000 members
this is supposed to be a massive
movement in the United States the DSA
they're riding across the land they're
taking over America the DSA with all
37,000 of their members okay by contrast
I have I think 30 times that number of
people who follow me on Twitter okay so
it's not a big membership so that's not
a huge membership but it is an
increasingly important membership
because the Democrats themselves have
embraced the principles of the
democratic socialists of America or at
least they're using them as the vanguard
if the DSA is basically the tea party of
the left so we thought occupy was gonna
be the tea party of the left occupy has
sort of morphed into the DSA and the DSA
has all of these newfangled figures who
are who are going to push the new
America they're gonna push the new
America and what exactly is their agenda
well the New York City Democratic
Socialist of America they've tweeted out
what their agenda is
here's what it looks like abolish profit
abolish prisons abolish cash bail
abolished
borders abolish ice a good luck with
that yeah you go ahead and you try that
abolished prophet tweeted presumably
from an iphone abolish prisons tweeted
while you're not being assaulted by a
prisoner abolish borders tweeted from a
country called America where you have to
actually be vetted to get in so if this
is their actual agenda and this is the
agenda the democrats are now embracing
kirsten gillibrand over the weekend said
that she no longer wants ice to be a
thing so if you think the DSA isn't
becoming a thing you're wrong it is
becoming a thing here's Kirsten
Gillibrand the most malleable member of
the US Senate
remember when she joined the US Senate
she was pro-gun and only quasi
pro-choice and now Kristin Gillibrand
has turned into a radical left winger
because she wants to run for president
as the as the Hillary Clinton younger
clone so here she is talking about
dumping immigration and customs
enforcement she doesn't have any
substitute for ice she doesn't say well
let's just start a new branch outside
the Homeland Security Department she
just says let's dump ice which man it is
amazing how fast the radicals on the
Left are being mainstreamed into the
Democratic Party we should protect
families that need our help and that is
not what ice is doing today and that's
why I believe you should get rid of it
start over
reimagine it and build something that
actually works what does that even mean
what does it mean to reimagine it like
Willy Wonka's chocolate factory
reimagine it like what about like dr.
Seuss is Imaginarium like we're going to
we're going to sit around we're going to
blue sky about how to take care of the
borders you need somebody who actually
wants to police the border you idiot
okay so Kirsten Gillibrand making a fool
of herself and then Elizabeth Warren's
doing the same thing so Elizabeth Warren
when she first entered the Senate she
was not considered the radical that she
is now she'd written a book a very
famous book about what she called the -
the the - income trap that basically
America I had had lowered its its
standard of living in certain ways
because both parents were now expected
to work which was considered by many
conservatives kind of an interesting
argument because it was basically
suggesting that maybe a one parent
family income would be better that maybe
one of the parents should stay home and
we should build society around that so
there are a lot of family oriented
conservatives who actually liked
Elizabeth Warren's book way back when
well now Elizabeth Warren is a full
scale Kirsten Gillibrand idiot and so
she has decided that she also is against
ice this is the new thing say you're
against ice now let's be clear about
this Americans are not in favor of this
position seventy percent of Americans
think I sought to exist and that we
ought to be in
forcing our boarders this is a 70/30
issue for Republicans but it is a 70/30
issue among Democrats that ice should be
abolished
so everybody is now swiveling to take
care of the radical base hoping they'll
win twenty20 primaries
here's Elizabeth Warren's doing the same
thing as Kirsten Gillibrand all of them
now mirroring the Democratic socialists
of America have made it obvious we need
to rebuild our immigration system from
top to bottom starting by replacing us
with something that reflects what does
that even mean something that reflects
our morality well what what is that like
I can't even imagine what that would be
replacing ice is literally a police
force that's what it does it is there to
police the borders what is she even
talking about but the radicalism in the
Democratic Party now runs deep and
they've decided they're gonna swivel to
the Bernie Sanders left in order to in
order to rev up the base so Maxine
Waters she disowns Nancy Pelosi and
Chuck Schumer saying that they will do
anything to protect their leadership
what we need to be is more radical this
is auntie Maxine a lady who a week ago
was saying that people should be mobbed
at gas stations and driven out of public
life I was surprised that Chuck Schumer
you know reached into the other house to
do that I have not quite seen that done
before but one of the things that
recognized being an elected official is
in the final analysis you know
leadership like Chuck Schumer's will do
anything that they think is necessary to
protect their leadership so she's saying
that the Chuck Schumer is only being
civil because he's trying to protect his
leadership the reality is the Maxine
Waters has been a radical her entire
career she used to call the Los Angeles
Riots the LA rebellion the LA uprising
while it's happening 73 people died in
those riots and she was out there
cheering it on Maxine Waters is the
worst that the United States Congress
has to offer and she is being seen as a
charming figure on the left and she says
the people want us to be confrontational
the only people who want confrontation
in American society right now are the
far left people in the hardcore base of
the left here here she is again on joy
Reid's execrable show on MSNBC people do
want to see us be stronger and more
forceful and to confront them on these
policies and I'm hopeful that even
Democrats haven't seen
of the count of outpouring of protest
over 700 incidences of protests this
weekend saying that they will be more
forceful more confrontational and more
prepared to push back on this
administration so people should be more
confrontational that's what America
needs more confrontation so abolish iced
embrace democratic socialism and
confront people on the streets this is
the new democratic party this is what
Trump has driven them to they really
believe that they're gonna remake the
world in their image this way and it's
it's pretty incredible it's pretty
incredible we're gonna go a little bit
further in this direction I want to talk
about the movement of the mainstream
toward Maxine Waters and and Alexandria
Lok Asya Cortes and all the rest of us I
want to talk a little bit out whether
democratic socialism actually works
because there's a lot of myths that are
floating around about democratic
socialism in just a second first I want
to talk about your loans
okay the reality is that for decades
credit cards have been telling us to buy
now and pay for it later with interest
the problem is the interest rates aren't
astronomical
that interest gets out of control fast
this is how people ruin their lives but
people still need money and that's why
you need to talk to my friends over at
Lending Club you can consolidate your
debt or pay off credit cards with one
fixed monthly payment since 2007 Lending
Club has helped millions of people
regain control of their finances with
affordable fixed-rate personal loans no
trips to a bank no high interest credit
cards go to Lending Club calm and tell
them about yourself and how much you
want to borrow and pick the terms that
are right for you if you're approved
your loan is automatically deposited
into your bank account in as little as a
few days Lending Club is the number one
peer-to-peer lending platform with over
35 billion dollars in loans issued so
all you have to do is go over to Lending
Club comm slash pen get your finances in
order folks you're gonna need to do it
Lending Club comm slash pen you can
check your rate in minutes and borrow up
to 40 grand
that's Lending Club comm slash
Bennigan's Lending Club comm /ban
there's no reason for you to continue
paying those extremely high interest
rates on the credit cards instead of
going and getting a much lower interest
rate over at Lending Club dot-com /ban
all loans were made by webb bank member
FDIC Equal Housing lender go check it
out Lending Club com slash pennies that
slash pen lets them know that we say you
okay so I want to talk more about why it
is the democratic socialism is a giant
fail why the Democrats are embracing it
plus a little bit of Supreme Court talk
in just a second but first you're gonna
have to go over to Daley wire comm for
$9.99 a month to get the rest of this
show live you also get the rest of
Andrew
Levens show live Michael Mills July but
that's a thing that you're interested in
and when you get the annual subscription
you get this the very finest in all
beverage vessels the leftist tiers hot
or cold tumbler now with any level of
subscription you also get to ask
questions in the mailbag and later today
we are having on Jordan Peterson for a
July 4th episode in which you will be
able to ask Jordan questions as well so
you want to become a subscriber so he
can do all of those things just $9.99 a
month or 99 bucks a year go check it out
it's a live wire comm also make sure
that you check us out at YouTube and
iTunes please subscribe please leave us
a review we always have great Sunday
specials coming out that you won't get
unless you're a subscriber over at
iTunes or use we just had to Adam
Carolla on it was hilarious and fun and
next week I believe is Sam Harris
correct so Sam Harris is coming up next
week so that should be a blast
so go go subscribe leave a serve you go
check it out we are the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast in
the nation
[Music]
so here's the problem as the Democrats
move more radical people are going so
crazy that even people who used to be
supposedly conservative although not all
that conservative have been echoing some
of the more extreme rhetoric of the left
see America is on a pendulum and it
swings side-to-side Barack Obama was a
radical guy and now it is swiveled to
president Trump who is a very strong
conservative in office okay that means
that when the pendulum swings back it's
gonna swing back to the Democratic Party
well if the Democratic Party is a party
of democratic socialism meaning it's
just a socialist party then what you're
going to see is an exacerbation of the
conflicts that is driving America into
the ground right now it's really ugly
stuff Jennifer Rubin who used to be a
sane person but apparently not anymore I
met her at Bill Maher she was in the
green room I said hello she's a
perfectly nice lady except that she says
crazy things now she says that Sarah
Huckabee Sanders right the the White
House press secretary that she should be
made to feel uncomfortable in public
places this is the kind of country she
wants now Huckabee has no right to live
a life of no fuss no muss after lying to
the press after inciting against the
press these people should be made
uncomfortable and I think that's a life
sentence frankly it's a life sentence to
be made uncomfortable like dad's it
really that's what we're gonna do so
okay I assume that the same applies to
general band then so if Jen Rubin is out
eating at a restaurant I think that her
political perspective is obnoxious and I
encourage people to harass her at
restaurants then presumably that's
totally fine with her because after all
this is the new politics in that this
sort of polarization is really quite
terrible for the country there's a piece
in The New York Times talking about the
embrace of full-scale socialism by the
Democrats by Michelle Goldberg talking
about the fact that this that this this
woman Alexandra Ocasio Cortez 28 knocked
off Joe Crowley in a primary vote in New
York and some early who's 30 and Sarah
innamorato who's 32 and Elizabeth
Fiedler 37 all three of them won
nominations for the Pennsylvania State
Legislature in the Democratic Party all
of them are members of the Democratic
socialists of America Michelle Goldberg
says Millennials are embracing socialism
in large numbers quote talk of popular
control of the means of production is
anathema to many older Democrats even
very liberal ones right because they
have a memory and they remember what it
was like in the Soviet Union they
remember that Cuba is still a place
remember that North Korea is garbage
that when the government controls the
means of production terrible things
generally happen
younger Democrats believe that the only
way to counter President Trump is to
counter the entire system this is the
pitch that the left has been making it's
not a pitch in favor of their own
program and the success of it it's a
program in favor of its it's a pitch in
favor of a replacement of the entire
hierarchy with something brand-new Trump
is the product of this hierarchy and if
the hierarchy can be destroyed if the
first amendment can be destroyed if the
second amendment can be destroyed and a
private property can be destroyed then
we will no longer have to suffer with
Trump it's not that Trump is a product
of a broken civility in our politics
which it really more is it's not that
President Trump is the product of an
increasing polarization in our politics
it's not the president Trump is a
backlash the hardcore leftism of left
it's that President Trump is himself a
product of the evil American system and
that system must be torn out root and
branch Michelle Goldberg who's a friend
of these socialists she says this
position popular controls of the means
of production it plays a lot better with
the young one recent survey shows that
61% of Democrats between 18 and 34 view
socialism positively indeed well there's
a lot of talk about an ideological civil
war among Democrats on the ground
boundaries seem more fluid in
Pennsylvania recently I met with
moderate suburban resistance activists
who volunteered for innamorato
thrilled to support a young woman who
could help revitalize the Democratic
Party and this is the entire issue for
the Democrats the agenda of the DSA is
utterly insane nationalized health care
guaranteed housing guaranteed government
jobs although it bankrupt the United
States and five seconds the Democratic
Party is happy to embrace that crowd
because so long as they can wield that
crowd like a club against President
Trump they're happy to do it
meanwhile I love this Goldberg says the
young members of the DSA are hopeful
because their analysis helps them make
sense of the Trump catastrophe they
often seem less panicked about what is
happening in America right now than
liberals are because they believe they
know why our society is coming undone
and how it can be rebuilt
so right now socialists are on the rise
there are more candidates like Ocasio
Cortes out there the Democrats should
welcome them it needs their youth and
zeal and willingness to do the work of
rebuilding the party as a neighborhood
institution and they're coming whether
the party's leadership likes it or not
my favorite part of the article is where
Michelle Goldberg suggests that all of
these socialists are very kind to one
another as I was struck by the work they
put into building community on some days
that public schools are closed the D s a
socialist feminist committee puts on
all-day events with childcare and free
lunches like several other chapters the
Pittsburgh
ESA holds clinics remembers change
people's burned out car brake lights for
free helping them avoid unnecessary
police run-ins while making inroads into
the community a local mechanic named
metal Mary helped train them here's the
problem all that comes to an end the
minute the socialist takeover government
because there is no reason there's no
rationale whatsoever for them to
actually do community outreach the
minute that the government can do all of
it it's just a delight now let's talk
for a second about the appeal of
democratic socialism because what you
hear from the left of the democratic
socialism is what exists in places like
Denmark and Sweden that is real
socialism there's only one problem none
of this is true
nema son Anton ji who writes for the
stream he has a very good piece about
myths regarding Nordic socialism he's an
author and researcher heald's a PhD from
the Royal Institute of Technology in
Sweden and conducted research at the at
the University of Cambridge and he has a
great piece about why it is that so many
people think that Democratic Socialist
Republics are the ones that are really
succeeding when in reality they're
succeeding in spite of their socialism
so here's what he says the success of
Nordic countries is based on the fact
that historically they have relied on
free markets and protection of private
property the only exception is a short
period in Sweden where in socialist
policies crippled growth and job
creation Nordic nations do have high
taxes and generous welfare but in many
other regards they have unusually free
markets Danish Prime Minister Lars
Rasmussen says after seeing his country
held up as an example in the American
presidential debate he told students in
a 2015 speech at Harvard's Kennedy
School of Government quote I know that
some people in the u.s. associate the
Nordic model with some sort of socialism
therefore I would like to make one thing
clear Denmark is far from a socialist
planned economy Denmark is a market
economy when it comes to areas such as
business regulations trade policy
investment freedom vouchers in the
provision of education elderly care and
health care and partial privatization of
retirement savings nordic countries are
among the most free market in the world
hey Nordic countries did not become rich
by relying on socialism Sweden is the
only Nordic country that actually
experimented with socialism in the 70s
and 80s and instead it destroyed so it's
destroyed Sweden's economy from 1970 to
1991 Social Democrats tried to introduce
his form of plant economy into the
country and Sweden's growth rate fell to
the second lowest among Western European
countries after being among the highest
also there are a lot of people who say
well look at these Swedish the Sweden
and
mark and Norway look at their wonderful
wonderful lifespans and low child
mortality there's only one problem
they're low child mortality and
lifespans pre-existed the socialist
attempts to remake their economy in 1960
the tax rate in Denmark was 25 percent
of GDP lower than 27 percent in the u.s.
at the time and all of their outcomes
were just the same or higher than they
are now
the top 10 countries is longest lifespan
in 1960 when these were all capitalist
Norway Iceland Netherlands Sweden
Denmark Switzerland it's exactly the
same now except that they've actually
dropped a little bit and they had low
child mortality rates too and finally
important to note that if you're talking
about why Denmark does better Sweden
does better Scandinavian Americans do
best
Scandinavia does better important to
note all of these groups when they come
to America do better in the United
States and they do back in their home
countries so in Denmark Danish Americans
actually do better in America than they
do in Denmark so all of the talk about
how how all of these countries are
thriving because of socialism is just
isn't true now the reason I say this the
reason that I bring all this up is
because of something that is quite
hilarious
all of these millennial socialists are
not socialists all of these millennial
socialists grew up in the lap of luxury
they grew up in capitalist luxury and
the same thing is true in all these
Nordic countries all these Nordic
countries became wealthy because they
embraced free markets and capitalism and
all these countries in in Scandinavia
all of them were among the free trading
companies the most free trading
companies and countries in the 17th
century although I'll going all the way
back related to the 15th and 16th
centuries so the this idea that it was
socialism that made these countries rich
is just absurd what it really was was
socialism redistributing all of the
gains that have been made in capitalism
and all of these countries including
Denmark still have very free markets
when it comes to attraction of business
they just have incredibly high tax rates
they can tamp down the growth of
individual industry and the reason that
I bring this up is because this
Alexander Ocasio Court has become this
big star now right this
twenty-eight-year-old star from New York
it turns out that she has been living
off the benefits and excesses of
capitalism for her entire life she grew
up in Westchester County ok she didn't
grow up impoverished in government
housing and she she's not she doesn't
really have a working-class background
so the hardest part this is from the
daily
the hardscrabble biography of democrat
congressional candidate alexandria
Ocasio cortez has been called into
question after the revelation that she
grew up mostly in wealthy westchester
county though Acacio cortez 28 was born
in and currently lives in the bronx
county land records show her late father
Sergio Cortez Roman bought a quaint
three-bedroom in Yorktown Heights in New
York in 1991 when she was about two but
her biography says the state of Bronx
Public Schools in the late 80s and early
90s sent her parents on a search for a
solution she ended up attending public
school 40 minutes north New York town
and much of her life was defined by the
40-minute commute between school and her
family in the Bronx yeah except she grew
up in Westchester County she said to
choose a girl from the Bronx she's
refused to comment on all of this so
let's say that she's wildly wealthy but
she grew up in a nice middle-class
family her father who died tragically
from lung cancer in 2008 was an
architect and CEO of Kirschenbaum and
Ocasio Roman architects PC which focused
on remodeling and renovations okay she
was he was a small business owner so
again the idea that all of these people
are living in absolute poverty they
originally lived in a planned community
in Parkchester and then they moved down
they got a house they lived in a plant
community 171 mid-rise brick buildings
in the Bronx and when she was about five
they moved to this house in Westchester
County so we're supposed to believe that
she's not the the result of capitalism
by the way she seems to be pretty
capitalistic in her own life according
to the New York Post Ocasio Cortes used
to work at flats fix which is an East
16th Street taco and tequila bar and
most of her co-workers liked her a lot
but one waitress says that at the end of
one night when Ocasio Cortez was tending
bar at a Cinco de Mayo celebration in
2017 when it came time to split the 560
bucks and tips she'd gotten at the bar
al khazneh Cortez gave the waitress 50
bucks
after the waitress complained to her
manager her take was doubled to a
hundred bucks and this waitress says
that this says something about her
character so like a lot of socialists
it's all fun and games until it comes
time to stick the money in your own
pocket also this was pretty funny so
Cascio Cortez was on TV or actually she
was on Twitter and she'd been asked
about her her lipstick cuz she wears
this bright red lipstick and she tweeted
out I've been getting many inquiries
about my debate lip color in the last
few days I got you it's stylist stay all
day liquid and beso okay then it sold
out so the Socialists pitched a
capitalistic product and and it sold out
because this is still okay
holistic country and this is all this is
all stupidity okay quickly I'm gonna
talk briefly about Supreme Court so the
Supreme Court president Trump is talking
about what he wants to do at the Supreme
Court and he says that abortion could
end up with the states you could see the
overturning of roe v wade from Trump's
mouth to God's ears here's President
Trump talking about it the Rovi were you
know Wade is probably the one that
people are talking about in terms of
having an effect but we'll see what
happens but it could very well end up
with States at some point so yeah I mean
yeah I hope he's right people on the
Left they're going nuts over all of its
they suggest that it's terrible we can
never overturn roe v wade one of those
people of course is the idiot Susan
Collins the senator from Maine and I
hear she is saying that she won't vote
for anyone who demonstrates anti-ro
opinion I would not support a nominee
who demonstrated hostility to roe v wade
because that would mean to me that their
judicial philosophy did not include a
respect for established decisions
established law okay so it's it's
established law according to Susan
Collins except for every bad decision
was established law Plessy versus
Ferguson which said that segregation was
legal was established law for 58 years
in the United States before Brown versus
Board of Education a case in the United
States that said that same-sex marriage
could be made illegal by states
okay that was law in the United States
for 44 years whenever people on the Left
say precedent what they really mean is a
decision that I like Susan Collins is is
a fool when it comes to roe v wade it
should be overturned because it's a
terrible decision and I hope that it
will be okay so in just a second we'll
do some stuff I like and some stuff that
I hate I have plenty of stuff I like in
stuff I hate so let's jump in
things I like today so I already told
you about Dan Jones's book on the
Plantagenet she has a sequel to that
called the War of the Roses really
fascinating if you if you liked the
series the white queen on showtime then
check out the the War of the Roses Linda
Brown stars the white queen but the War
of the Roses is it's really fun to read
if you like British history it's really
enjoyable so go check that out because
we can all use a break from politics
every once in a while okay time for a
bunch of things that I hate you ready
for a lot of hate because here it comes
man
okay we begin today with Don Woollett so
Don Willet is a super he's a court
justice he's a judge on the I believe
Fifth Circuit Court of Appeals and
justice Willett as he calls himself on
Twitter he stopped tweeting as soon as
he was appointed to a federal appellate
court he was on the Texas Supreme Court
and I was being discussed for a possible
Supreme Court pick while ABC ran an
entire piece on why John Willett should
not be allowed on the Supreme Court
because of his sweets they quoted for
tweets here were the tweets that they
quoted okay one from from judge Willett
saying people of Earth in 2018 justice
will it will never give you up let you
down run around desert you make you cry
say goodbye to oh i or hurt you right
they say and this tweet makes it
impossible for me to be on the Supreme
Court or if it's not that one maybe it's
this one okay tweets out eleven-year-old
daddy why do politicians talk about
eminent to Eminem is domain me that's
eminent domain 11 year old huh me sorry
you only get one shot okay so those dad
jokes on Twitter according to ABC
because Don Willett does dad jokes on
Twitter we should bar him from the
Supreme Court so if you are not a wild
leftist or you do dad jokes on Twitter
that means you cannot be allowed on the
Supreme Court maybe the left thinks that
the Supreme Court's just a tool policy
okay here is Don Willick sweeted this
one out my three favorite chocolate
positively positively it's a picture of
three dogs dark white and milk okay this
is what he is not he can't be allowed on
the Supreme Court because he's tweeting
out cute pictures of puppies maybe you
guys are going a little bit overboard on
this whole thing maybe you're just a
little bit overboard on this whole thing
so well done ABC really vetting the
candidates the way they must be vetted
we need to make sure that Donaghy cannot
we cannot have a man who tweets about
puppies on the Supreme Court we just
cannot it would just be too terrible
okay time for another thing that I hate
so LeBron is heading to LA as Boston
Celtics fan this saddens me it also
makes me happy in one way which is that
LeBron is no longer in the East but I
will say that LeBron James moving over
to the Lakers to try and build another
super team I guess it's good for the NBA
because a good storyline as opposed to
him staying in Cleveland but can we now
all acknowledge the him going back to
Cleveland was not something that he was
doing for altruistic reasons he was
something that he was doing for career
reasons because now he's coming out to
LA he wants to make lunch our Hollywood
connections he's been in a bunch of
movies already
that's fine listen I'm
favor of free agency and people being
able to move wherever they want I like
job malleability I like you being able
to choose where you want to go but let's
not pretend that that that he's doing
this out of reasons of principle that
he's going to the Lakers out of reasons
of principle because that's just silly
he's doing it for the money he's doing
it for the publicity that's fine but you
know is it something I think that's good
for his sports legacy probably not
particularly okay also this I have to
show you so Huffington Post is now
pitching dragged children this has
become a thing there's become a thing on
the left that they're a bunch of eight
to ten year old kids boys who decide to
dress up as drag queens and now we're
being promoted by their parents and put
in the media so I have a general problem
with child actors as it is just a whole
I think it's a huge mistake for parents
to get their children into acting
publicly because I don't think the
children should be exposed to public
discourse as a general rule I think the
kids don't know enough about what they
want their own minds they're not capable
of making reasoned decisions they're not
capable of making good decisions I think
it is particularly awful for parents to
be exploiting their ten-year-old boys by
dressing them up as girls or allowing
them to dress up as girls
and parade them in front of cameras
looking like drag queens because this is
somehow good for them these are ten year
olds they're not capable you wouldn't
allow your 10 year old to decide whether
or not to do his homework that night why
would you allow him he's not the
hormones haven't even hit at ten years
old this kid doesn't know he's gay he's
10 years old yeah I mean unless he had
an early onset puberty he doesn't he
hasn't it probably hasn't thought about
sex yet he's 10 okay but we're supposed
to believe that this kid is is somehow
doing something brave and wonderful
according to Huffington Post this is a
form of child abuse
here's Huffington Post promoting it it's
a it's this is a ten-year-old boy who if
you can't see is wearing a blonde wig
and blue lipstick dressed up as a drag
queen I was born inside mom in the year
2007 gay pride means self-expression
stop it for a second this kid is 10
years old
how in the hell is this kid an LGBTQ
activist first of all ten year olds
should not be activist about anything
anything the only thing you can fairly
make a case for on politics why
ten-year-old should be activists is
maybe I'm pro-life issues
because they're not dead but otherwise
even then I wouldn't use a kid as an
activist for pro-life cause and I love
pro-life clauses but to make a kid an
activist on sexual matters is perverse
okay it's actually perverse if there
were an adult who are not this kid's
parents you dress this kid up this way
and put this kid in public you wouldn't
know that this was something perverse
and that's what Huffington Post is
Huffington Post is into these kids
parents but it's just it's absurd
there's more of this there's more of
this it's just it's as a parents with
your children I cannot imagine doing
anything remotely like this to my kid
even my kid wanted to dress like this
even though I thought it was okay for my
kids to dress like this putting my kid
in front of cameras and playing that as
an act of bravery on my part is just
disgusting no matter what anyone says
and pay no mind okay can you stop for a
second again so that's the end of it I
think so this is so this kid notice the
use of the word fierce there okay this
is because this kid has been culturally
indoctrinated into the use of certain
terms right three year old five year
olds ten year olds they don't know the
word fierce unless you have been engaged
in a particular culture that glorifies a
particular set of values and listen as
your parent if that's what as a parent
if that's what you want to do and it's
not damaging your kid that's one thing
but to trot this kid out as an activist
as a free-minded activist he's really
quite grown to be 18 and do this again
that's your prerogative you want to be
you want to be 25 and you don't need an
adult and do this that's your
prerogative this is a parent who decided
that they were going to get their kid
some attention and decided that it was
that they were going to therefore
encourage these sorts of tendencies in
the kid you think this kid isn't going
to experience are harder to life I'm not
even talking about quote-unquote
oppression from from people outside of
this kid I'm not even talking about
bullying which of course is not
appropriate in any case when I am
talking about here is that confusing
kids about their own sexual identity and
gender at the age of 10 and not
attempting to provide them any sort of
solid grounding for this stuff before
they even hit puberty is not a recipe
for mental health just it's about the
entire left would would suggest an
intolerance say this the only form of
tolerance is to cheer
long as a ten-year-old kid is dressed up
in drag queen outfits and paraded in
front of the the drooling media it
really is really quite horrifying okay
final thing that I hate for today so
president Trump has now leaked a draft
bill this new draft bill would declare
America's abandonment of fundamental
World Trade Organization rules so I
can't imagine this is going to pass the
bill essentially provides President
Trump a license to raise US tariffs at
will without congressional consent and
international rules be damned
the bill is titled the u.s. fair and
reciprocal tariff act in other words the
u.s. fart Act K would give President
Trump unilateral power to ignore the two
most basic principles of the WTO and
negotiate one-on-one with any country
most favored nation principle that
countries can't set tariff rates for
different countries outside of free
trade agreements and bound tariff rates
the tariff ceilings that each WTO
country has already agreed to in
previous negotiations so it's walking
away from our current commitments on
tariffs it's walking away from free
trade it is not president from
negotiating better trade deals it is
president Trump manipulating tariffs
which is something he likes to do no way
in hell should Congress give him this
Authority it first of all it's
legislative authority in general second
of all I do not trust President Trump
with trade authority given what it is
that he has done with trade thus far
okay we will be back here tomorrow with
all the latest i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Sonia Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wah of era the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright Ford
publishing 2018